les députés en revanche un ont rendu
contraignants le vote des actionnaires
sur la rémunération des patrons mais
n'ont pas voté l'encadrement de ces
rémunérations vous le regrettez oui le
bois je pense que c'est ce qui était
proposé initialement était un premier
pas moi évidemment je suis pour un
écrasement beaucoup plus important de 1
à 20 je suis même pour de 1,4 de 1,6
même si vous voulez fola de le plus
petit salaire de l'entreprise
l'écart entre le plus petit salaire et
le plus d le plus grand dans
l'entreprise je suis plutôt pour ça
parce que il est urgent de revenir à de
la justice dans notre pays
le l'ingénieur celui qui dès que
découvre une molécule celui qui est dans
laboratoire comme l'ouvrier qui est qui
produit il a autant de valeur que celui
qui gère et qui dirige l'entreprise